you mentioned
the following line from the end of the
alan turing paper
uh computing machinery and intelligence
that many people
like you said many people know and very
few have read
where he proposes the turing test this
is this is how you know because it's
towards the end of the paper
instead of trying to produce a program
to simulate the adult mind
why not rather try to produce one which
simulates the child's
so that's a really interesting point if
i think about the benchmarks we have
before us the the the tests
of our computer vision systems they're
often kind of trying to
get to the adult so what kind of
benchmarks should we have
what kind of tests for computer vision
do you think we should have
that mimic the child's in computer
vision yeah
i think we should have those and we
don't have those today
and i think uh the part of that
the challenge is that we should really
be collecting data
of the type that a child uh that the
child experiences
right so that gets into issues of you
know privacy and so on and so forth
but there are attempts in this direction
to sort of try to collect
the kind of data that a child encounters
growing up so what's the child's
linguistic environment what's the
child's visual environment
so if we could collect that kind of data
and then develop learning schemes based
on that data
that would be one way to do it
i i i think that's a very promising
direction myself
there might be people who would argue
that we could just short circuit this in
some way
and uh sometimes uh
we have imitated uh we have not
we have had success by not imitating
nature in detail so
the usual example is airplanes right we
don't build flapping winds
flapping wings so uh
yes that's uh that's one of the points
of debate
uh in my mind i i i would i would bet on
this this learning like a child approach
so one of the fundamental aspects of
learning like a child is the
interactivity
so the child gets to play with the data
set it's learning from
yes it gets to select i mean you can
call that active learning you can
you know in the machine learning world
you can call it a lot of terms
what are your thoughts about this whole
space of being able to play with the
data set or select what you're learning
yeah so i think that i i believe in that
and i think that we could achieve it in
in two ways and i think we should use
both so one
is uh actually real robotics
right so real uh you know physical
embodiments of agents
who are interacting with the world and
they have a physical body with
dynamics and mass and moment of inertia
and friction and all the rest and you
learn your body the robot learns its
body by
doing a series of
actions the second is that simulation
environments
so i think simulation environments are
getting much much better
in my uh in my life in
facebook ai research our group has
worked on something called habitat
which is a simulation environment
uh which is a visually photorealistic
environment of
you know places like houses or interiors
of
various urban spaces and so forth and as
you move
you get a picture which is a pretty
accurate picture
so uh i i can now uh you can imagine
that
subsequent generations of these
simulators will be accurate not just
visually
but with respect to you know forces and
masses
and haptic interactions and so on
and then then we have that environment
to play with
i think that let me state one reason why
i think
this active being able to act in the
world is important i think that this is
one way to break
the uh correlation versus causation
barrier
so this is something which is of a great
deal of interest these days i mean
people like judea pearl have
talked a lot about why
that we are neglecting causality and he
describes the entire set of successes of
deep learning as just curve fitting
right because it's uh but i i don't
quite agree
as a troublemaker he is but causality is
important but causality is not
is not like a single silver bullet it's
not like one single principle there are
many different aspects here
and one of the ways in which uh
one of our most reliable ways of
establishing causal links and this is
the way
for example the the medical community
does this is
randomized control trials so you have
you
you pick some situation and now in some
situation you perform an action and
for certain uh others you don't
right so so you have a control
experiment well the child is in fact
performing controlled experiments all
the time
right right right okay small scale and
in a small scale and
but but that is a way that the child
gets to
build and refine its causal models of
the world
and my colleague alison gopnik has
together with a couple of authors
co-authors has this book called the
scientist in the crib
referring to children so i like the part
that i like about that is the scientist
wants to do wants to build causal models
and the scientist does control
experiments and i think the child is
doing that
so to enable that we will need to
have these these active experiments
and i think this could be done some in
the real world and some in simulation so
you have hope for simulation
i have hopefully solution that's an
exciting possibility if we can get to
not just photo realistic but what's that
called
life realistic yeah uh simulation
so you don't see any fundamental
blocks to why we can't eventually
simulate
the the the principles of what it means
to exist in the world
as a physical i i don't see any
fundamental problems there i mean
and look the computer graphics community
has come a long way
right so the in the early days back
going back to the 80s and 90s they were
they were focusing on visual realism
right and then they could do the easy
stuff but they couldn't do
stuff like hair or fur and so on
okay well they managed to do that then
they couldn't do physical
actions right like there's a bowl of
glass and it falls down and it shatters
but then they could start to do pretty
realistic models of that
and so on and so forth so the graphics
people have shown that they can do
this forward direction not just for
optical interactions but also for
physical interactions
so i think of course some of that is
very computer intensive but
i think by and by we will find ways of
making our models ever more realistic
you